[Music]
[Music]
recently I discussed the ending of the
new Netflix show maniac whilst I gave a
surface level account of the show's
final episode it's clear that there were
deeper things going on in the closing
scenes throughout this video I'll be
discussing my alternative ending theory
on the show as well as the evidence to
support it there will be heavy spoilers
so it may be worth skipping this video
for now if you're yet to finish the
program with that out the way I'm
definition and this is my alternative
ending theory on maniac maniac ending
wraps the storyline with a nice little
ball that sees our heroes ride off into
the sunset
it's the perfect finale for what our two
protagonists have just went through and
will leave many with a smile on their
face but did it actually happen
fans of films such as Inception and
Total Recall know that when a piece of
media contains skews on reality it can
often be difficult for characters to
discern what is real and what is fake by
the end and mania is no different
throughout the show we get little hints
that the two characters Annie and Owen
may still be living in a dream world the
biggest red flag is that the finale is a
fantasy that Owen described to Annie
earlier in the show and it seems
unlikely that something he envisioned
would come to fruition so perfectly
especially with the poor situation that
he finds himself in at the shows clothes
another signifier that this is all a
dream is the fact that we see two parked
cars in the close of the show which are
the same ones that Bruce and owen drove
in their simulations we also witness
Annie sign her name as Wendy Lemuria
which is a reference to Wendy at the
Lima the name Urich appears further up
the list which is of course a call from
the elfin fantasy that Annie was a part
of some have argued that the machine was
pulling in elements from the real world
however the points I've just mentioned
make it impossible in my eyes and
confirms that the entire event was just
a simulation in addition to this there
are also elements like the door called
being guessed correctly even though it
appeared in this
Malaysian first and reality later one of
the most incredible fan theories I've
heard also comes from the fact that Owen
witnesses trembling in the real world
and then later during the simulation
which could hint at the fact that all of
the events in the show including the
introductory episode or Park of a
simulation unfortunately with this being
a limited series it is unlikely that we
will ever get conclusive answers but
it's still fun to speculate on exactly
how the show ended and I can't wait to
unpick it in greater detail so what did
you think of maniac are they still in a
simulation or did everything end is
perfectly for the characters as they
perceive comment below and let me know
and I just want to give a huge thank you
to all those who left their thoughts on
my last video it massively helped them
putting together this one so make sure
you check that one out linked at the end
of this one if you enjoy this video then
please like it and subscribe to my
channel as I create breakdowns like this
weekly and they'll definitely be
something on here that you love if
you're a fan of television thanks again
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best and
I'll see you next time take care peace
you